every year on the night of cultural
brands guests representing business
cultural institutions the media and
politics gather for a celebration in
Berlin the awards honor cultural
institutions as well as cultural
managers and sponsors from across Europe
episodic de prize honors those who meet
the criteria for artistic productions as
well as for cultural development and
diversity so we bring culture managers
and marketing specialists those who
usually work behind the scenes and we
bring them onto center stage stop findit
who in VFD Bruno the main prize went to
a cultural center called you hmm does
you is the 10th most frequently music
letter in German and we have a cultural
project that is uncommon for unusually
well known and undeniably an important
brand and that's why we have awarded the
cultural brand of the year 2016 to Dork
wonder you don't mandir you is a center
that aims to facilitate the arts and
cultural participation in the Western
industrial city of Dortmund
the project is housed in a former
brewery the seven-story tower hosts a
variety of temporary exhibitions plus
workshops for children young people and
adults in the summer local group stage
performances in front of the building on
weekends the space under the roof is
transformed into a dance floor the
project has been growing increasingly
popular in the city as for me the use a
fantastic laboratory that's completely
free of all limits Ken's yes but it
brings together many many people ideas
and projects hmmm the school blamed off
your face you makes us more
international and that's important built
in the mid-1920s the you housed the
fermentation and storage rooms of
Dortmund's Union brewery it was the
city's first high-rise with a light
installation that could be seen from far
away in the 1960s a cardboard view was
installed on the tower later it was made
of steel decorated in gold leaf in 1994
the building was abandoned it stood
derelict for years until it was finally
converted into a center for arts and
creativity in 2010 the region was named
a european capital of culture
the Dortmund au is a flagship project in
the truest sense of the word and a
fitting recipient for the European
cultural brand of the year this nvidia
troupe it's an important boost for us it
gives us and our work added momentum the
cultural sphere doesn't always have it
easy I think i'm on noise an award like
this can also raise our public profile
maybe give our work in the city and in
the state of north rhine-westphalia a
boost washtech verdict on the night
featured awards in a total of seven
categories which are all designed to
honor special cultural projects the
museum's party avene was awarded the
urban cultural prize the art and culture
center in downtown Vienna is home to
about 60 cultural facilities making it
one of the largest complexes of its kind
in the world the European cultural
tourism of the Year award went to grim
hi Matt in the German state of heifer
jurgen flim artistic director of the
Berlin State Opera was honored with a
Lifetime Achievement Award must be an
Italian dish we end the jury search for
every year of course are the distinctive
features divisions that distinguish a
branch from the rest is Otesaga the I in
America when their Massa updates but all
of the award winners share a special
vision an especially distinct brand
management episode every one of them art
has a vision one guy named Marco wanna
be Shawn Deutsche Welle is a partner of
the cultural brand Awards just one of
the reasons why DW Director General
Peter Limbaugh is also committed to the
project the double is extreme
viticulture has to market itself
effectively Deutsche Welle is also a
cultural media we ain't transport German
culture and European culture around the
world so our participation here or a
large and small brands innovative brands
are honored is a very appropriate
setting for us fitting the 2016 night of
cultural brands an evening where
European initiatives and sponsors come
together to honor the best of cultural
marketing
you